welcome to this video playing Walter
water from hose Deena time probably will
get a king's indian i'll just post your
Kings in yet the classical in hmm I have
a sneaky suspicion I think the sky is
playing the exchange ok this is that
tried something else and that's what you
get for voiding it playing you five
himself okay all I cannot take here
twice because the 80s so okay let's
attack the center it seems to be it
seems to be an online with that we're
here just go just drop producing young
e6 hang was hanging very quickly played
ok so this so terrible
now I can't take on behalf now this is
the real problem all that one maybe okay
let's let's take now you can take g7 and
take be five then I'm just lacking my
all info on bishop I can take that he
can take on on evade but this is this is
better I think okay well let's check the
night it does not have it does not have
a square to go to so if i move my night
away what's you something hmm maybe I
can try to trap this one he's always got
Bishop h6 song okay well if you go
squinty form I probably can move my
knight away here
came all 96 is not really the move that
helps nitey for may be attacking also
yeah come on attacking also be too
I can play c5c 5c 5 has a good move now
then I need to take with the night I did
do that okay I thought this would have
been good mm-hmm I'm not saying that
this is bad but the other move looked
strong to me okay more queen coming
takes I guess also introducing Queen f6
now I now I can also just take here no
reason not to only issue is this happen
i can try to put some pressure on this
but half this yeah now I have this
immense mod on c5 very strong piece only
is 7mm young if i move the Bishop to e6
he can take on b7 how to do that okay
maybe for the moment just just use the
king
yeah I only need one or two cones
consolidation moves and then it's over
yeah threatening group d 6 son property
6 quindi a tiny to move the bishop now I
can SB 7 s not hanging anymore just
let's say rook the 8b 6 and and Queen f6
or something while not giving away edges
have notices this would be enough just
keep them keep everything protected and
then my material win the game I've got
two pieces and a pawn against the rook
very comfortable okay well now I can
actually move that
now maybe maybe I can arrest the queen
of it doesn't have any great squares and
now I think he needs to trade queens I
think yeah well now he needs to tread
queens and then I can I can play this
end game yeah this is very nice
just some decent technical play required
you came take it may always just got
this check now this blunder c7 I
shouldn't do that
I can't do it rookie 17 FC check is c7
is hanging such an idiot I would have
596 I have 96 walking the two looks yeah
still this was unnecessary unnecessarily
complicated it was ok but I could have
made the task not more straightforward
just push the depot check check whoopty
form yeah I think he missed some chances
at the early light resigned early middle
game and after that he got into trouble
better all round here I'm in a minimun
retro be pretty sure I can a computer
does not agree I thought this is just
yeah well night c7 is a good resource
maybe yeah he just needs to take here
this is this is it and now it's a it's a
very very tricky affair if i move the
rook I'm just worse I mean here you can
just take it and in place against this
very weak King so I need to exchange
sake but it can play something like that
for instance I it's just ugly very ugly
me okay this is not good for black queen
bee to was even stronger than work at
seven and here needs to go see five yes
the only move 45 when I need to take and
lose some time and maybe that one that
idiots it's interesting the comps s
black is basically winning or better but
something like that looks you want it's
it's notoriously tricky so so easy to
learn to play one wrong move and then
explode yeah now this is now assess is
just
just lost basically I only need to avoid
any any big blunders g5 was much simpler
him I only yeah this is much simpler I
only saw this idea of somewhat later I
did didn't spoil anything what I played
but it was okay yeah I miscalculated
here but it didn't really matter this
was winning anyway it's lucky that this
worked alright thanks for watching